have you had a great love of your life
yes you have now we're getting somewhere
who was it it was years ago I can't say
his name it's no one famous oh and what
ruined that your fame no something that
haven't cheated no no what are you doing
something else no no I got to know what
did he do no no I'll take care of this
guy what did he do to you in he lied
about two things he lied and that's it
for you that's the line yeah it was
something serious yeah you do not need
that no you want somebody you feel safe
with yeah it is hard how we're with all
four years that's a little bit too long
told a lie oh hey I remember when you
were dating Samantha Ronson that was
wild I didn't think that was I talked
about that on the show you do what do
you what do you say on the show about
your friends only morning you are still
friends well yeah well we were always
more like best friends it's not your
thing
no but no on the show it's just in
relation to one of Mike who's one of the
VIP host
he says he's bi and people were kind of
mean to him about that right but he's
just like well I like what I like and I
just don't know
isn't it remote anymore mmm so I came to
I come to his defense a bit yeah you say
hey I was in a relationship with a girl
did people pass judgment on you during
that time oh my god why are people so
goddamn angry about it was the first one
that was like that came out about yeah
really but why it might for my age why
would you want to be angry about that
you know what I mean that's the part I
don't get weird
it's vicious